by Odin's hammer full has arrived so you
guys may notice that I'm in a slightly
different location it's simply because I
moved yes I moved this weekend and so
I'm in the process of setting up my room
I haven't put up any of my posters yet
so Thor is a very famous Marvel comic
that has been around for a very long
time lots of fans and to be honest I
don't know that much about it I had a
couple friends who really know a lot
about and after the movie he was just
telling me stuff and I was like how do
you know this and Thor's realm he's
about to become king his father Anthony
Hopkins is the current king right before
he's about to take the throne this big
event happens it starts a cataclysmic
war between them and the frost giants
which are these really really cool
blueish things with red eyes that are
just really creepy and awesome and great
makeup done with those things and I
don't really want to get much into the
plot but what happens eventually is the
Thor's vanished to earth where he meets
Natalie Portman's character thank
goodness oh my word and that works for a
lot of comedy because he's like this you
know God and he's in this room and he's
like bring me more of this drink I don't
like it Thor is a very enjoyable
superhero movie a very satisfying one I
really thought Chris Hemsworth was
greatest or he did a very good job he
was funny likeable Anthony Hopkins as
good as his father Natalie Portman I
just I always liked her
the special effects for Thor were very
good there were a few times when I
thought particularly when Thor was
flying that I thought they could have
used some work because there wasn't a
lot of fluidity to it and it didn't look
terribly graceful to me for the most
part of the special effects were
astounding very well done and the makeup
on these creatures these frost giants
was just excellent now I was so glad
they weren't always just some veiled CGI
army they had a
actual legit actors and makeup and
everything I really enjoyed that
the director kenneth branagh huh he's
made a lot of films and he's a very good
director however this is his first foray
into Hollywood you know big Hollywood
movies and I think that that might have
heard the film a little bit because he
seems to be a little unsure in regards
to fight scenes they're all enjoyable
but none of them are particularly
remarkable there is one scene in the
film that stands out as the best action
scene it's actually the big opening
action scene all the other action scenes
are very enjoyable but a lot of
explosions and kicks and stuff nothing
terribly remarkable you know what I mean
and I think a lot of that has to do with
the fact that for a large portion of the
film Thor is a human he doesn't have any
of his powers but it doesn't really hurt
the film because the film is so
enjoyable I was really looking forward
this movie to be honest it disappointed
me just a little bit but for the most
part I really enjoyed for the 3d was
pretty good however after the movies my
eyes stung and I don't think it's
because of for I think she's because of
3d in general I'm getting very sick of
3d I enjoyed Thor lots of fun good witty
dialogue funny moments I enjoyed Fast
Five more believe it or not but Thor is
still a lot of fun and so I'm going to
give a three and a half out of four
stars I wrestled with that rating a lot
I almost gave it three this is a mild
three and a half I'm gonna recommend
Thor definitely check it out woman make
me a sandwich I want a feast
Oh